el retorno a la tan ansiada normalidad
podría tardar mucho más de lo pensado es
la opinión del presidente del consejo
científico de francia quien advierte que
el aumento de los casos cuestiona que
las personas puedan volver a sus
actividades de manera ordinaria este año
el retorno a la normalidad no es ahora
podría ser en 2022 o 2023
las declaraciones de triunfos o adelfas
y sean en el momento en el que el pase
sanitario fue aprobado por el parlamento
francés y pone en duda la efectividad de
la medida el científico asegura que aún
con el certificado como requisito y las
discotecas éstas podrían seguir siendo
un importante foco de contagio
en diversos países europeos con altas
tasas de vacunación más altas que el
nuestro
acaban de mostrar que una serie de
contagios importantes habían comenzado
en los clubes nocturnos
mientras tanto muchos franceses se
sienten obligados a vacunarse para poder
acceder a lugares cotidianos como bares
restaurantes y cafés donde el pase
sanitario será pedido desde agosto
no tengo otra opción porque si solo
quiero caminar por la calle
es lo mínimo debo estar vacunado en
francia- se han aplicado 67 millones de
vacunas pero las infecciones no paran de
aumentar un gran porcentaje se debe a la
variante delta en agosto francia se
enfrentaría a 50.000 casos por día estos
son los retos inmediatos de un país que
atraviesa el inicio de una cuarta ola de
contagios a futuro según el asesor de
gobierno el desafío será la convivencia
de dos mundos uno de países ricos con
poblaciones altamente vacunadas y otro
de naciones menos favorecidas donde la
inmunidad de rebaño seguirá siendo un
sueño lejano